팝업 스토어가 가장 많이 열리는 곳이
이제 성수동이 성수동을 좀 돌면서
성수동의 조금 역사와 그리고 최근에
이제 뭐 매각된 사례라는 좀 소개해
드리도록 하겠습니다 한번 저랑
이동하면서 좀 이야기를 들어
[음악]
보시죠 잠깐 차 한잔하러 왔는데 어
르의 알래스카 아고 원래 이제
신사동에 있던 빵집입니다 근데 거기
이제 임대차 기간이 끝나고 그 전에
이제 여기 건물을 사셨어요 연무장
길에 예 그래서 지금 여기 이제
매장을 직접 쓰고 계시는데 무엇보다
일단 위치가 너무 좋습니다 연무 장들
지금 거의 한 중간쯤 어 메인에
위치하고 있는데 업무를 너무 잘
사셨죠 그리고 또 혹시 추천해 주시면
한게 있을까요 제일 많이 나 아 이거
호드 크랜베리 빵빵 아 저 뒤에도
있어요 좌석이 아네 원래는 여기
막아서 테이크아웃만 하다가요네네 아
확장하거나네이 원래 빵지 건물이거나
[음악]
네 그래서 제가 디올 앞으로 가는데
그 경비원 분들이 너무 많더라고요 좀
촬영이 어려울 것 같아서 좀 뒤로
왔습니다네 그래서 저기 뒤에 보이는
어 저기 이제 뒤에 올 건물인데 원래
저기가 그 택시 운전 하던 그런
차오지 있어요 예 그리고 지금 소유도
1987년도에 어 택시 회사에서
매입해서 지금까지 가지고 있습니다
그래서 무려 한 37년 동안 존버를
했습니다 존버 하면 면 지금 이렇게
디올 어 팝업 스토어가 좀 들어와
있고 21년도 계약을 했는데 채권
최고액이 그때 한 40억 5천 정도
되더라고요 그리고 이제 1년 뒤에
20억 초반 정도로 좀 내려왔어요
그래서 차액이 한 18억 정도 되는데
예상컨데 월 차임이 한 1억 5천
정도 되지 않을까 뭐 이렇게 좀
예상을 하고 있습니다 그래서 지금 한
필지에 두 개 건물 있어요 뭐 디오이
신축했습니다 수도 있고 아니면 이제
건물주분이 그 설계에 맞게 신축을 해
줬을 수도 있습니다 계약 내용
모르겠지만 아무튼이 디오리 신축하면서
여기 관광객들이 많이 왔을 때 이쪽에
좀 이제 포토스팟으로 좀 많이 하는
거 같아요 그래서 사진 찍어 가지고
sns 좀 많이 올리고 하는 거
같습니다 보시면은 팝업 스토어가 좀
많이 열려 있어요 그래서 제가 그
기사를 보니까 4월 달에 성수동의
팝업 스토어 열린게 무려 87개
된다고 합니다네 그만큼 팝업 스토어가
되게 인기가 많고 월 임대료를 좀
보니까 어 한 실면적 한 70평 정도
쓰는데 무려 1억 5천입니다 그
명동보쌈 수준의 어 팝업스토어
임대료가 좀 설정이 돼 있는데 단기
임대기 때문에 그 상가 임대차 보법에
적용을 받지 않아요 그래서 그런 점
때문에 좀 임대료를 되게 좀 높게
책정할 수 있고 근데 물론 이제 이게
성도 군청에서 좀 얘기가 많더라고요
어 특히 연무장길 같은 경우에는 좀
팝업 스토어 성지라고 좀 보시면 될
거 같습니다 뭐 요즘만 아니라 전부터
트렌드가 기존의 그 느낌들을 다 살려
놔요 그니까 건물을 아예 다 부
가지고 신축하는게 아니라 기존 건물
느낌 그대로 좀 살려놔서 이렇게
리모델링 하는 경우가 많이 있습니다
그래 저는 성수동이 개인적으로 그
서울숲이 너무 좋아요 어 서울숲
얘기를 좀 하자면 원래 거기가
경마장이 있거든요 그래서 예전 분들
막 얘기 들어보면 아 거기 가면 막
진짜 말똥 냄새난다 막 그랬었는데
아무튼 그게 지금 이제 서울숲으로
바뀌었는데 서울 수비 일단 너무
좋잖아요 그래서 저는 개인적으로
거주하기에 그렇게 공원이 근처에
있는게 너무 좋더라고요 어 임대료에
대해서 좀 설명드리자면 지난해
3분기에 어 성수동 평당 임대료가 한
24만 원어요 정도 되더라고요 근데
이제 그
22년도는 한 18만 원 정도였는데
무려 한 38.5% 올랐습니다
2018년도와 비교해서는 한 두세 배
정도 더 올랐어요 그래서 그만큼 되게
임대료가 좀 가파르게 오르고 있는
곳이고 그 제가 봤을 때 그 데이터에
아마 팝업 스토어 임대료는 산정이 안
돼 있을 것 같거든요 그래서 아마
그것까지 산정하면 아마 대한민국에서
제일 높을 것 같 근데 이제 많은
분들이 원래 이제 기존에 공장
있으셨던 분들 그런 분들이 이제 다
쫓겨나면서 젠트리피케이션 때문에 좀
문제가 좀 많이 있는 거 같아요
그래서 그 정도로 좀 임대료가
가파르게 오르고 있는 곳인 거
같습니다네 오늘 좀 성수동을
돌아봤습니다 어 여러분들 좀
어떠셨나요 어 굉장히 진짜 올 때마다
좀 매번 바뀌고 있는데 어 여러분들도
성수동에 오셔서 계속 이렇게 변화되고
앞으로 좀 어떻게 변화할지 좀
지켜보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 오늘
영상 여기까지 하겠습니다 감사합니다
l
[음악]